mesdames et messieurs bonsoir une
catastrophe inexpliquée en italie 55
morts 180 blessés ce matin à la gare de
bologne à la suite d'une explosion sous
l'effet de la déflagration les salles
d'attenté le restaurant de la gare se
sont littéralement écroulées évidemment
en ce premier samedi d'août il y avait
beaucoup de monde pour les départs en
vacances ce qui explique le nombre
impressionnant de victimes je le
rappelle 55 morts 180 blessés et ce
matin vers 10h30 que sur près de 150 m
toutes les droites de la gare de bologne
a été complètement ravagé poutrer blocs
de pierre se sont écroulés sur les
wagons partance
il ya d'abord eu un énorme bang raconte
un témoin ri de la fumée et le silence
et nous avons vu que toute une partie de
la gare s'était effondré une immense
verrière s'est écrasé sur un train
spécial qui partait pour bâle sent bien
que mal les sauveteurs ont dégagé les
blessé et évacué les victimes
le bilan provisoire s'élève donc à 55
morts et 180 blessés dont plusieurs
gravement atteints selon la préfecture
de bologne
pour l'instant les causes de la
catastrophe ne sont pas déterminées
l'hypothèse la plus plausible serait
l'explosion d'une chaudière dans la
salle d'attenté seconde place
plusieurs témoins auraient d'ailleurs
ressenti une forte odeur de gaz avant
les déflagrations
pourtant près de trois heures après
l'explosion elle était revendiquée par
les noyaux armées révolutionnaires
mouvement d'extrême droite par une
communication téléphonique anonyme
rappelons qu'il ya six ans presque jour
pour jour le 4 août 74,1 attentats
d'extrémistes de droite avait provoqué
dans le train italicus rome munich pour
être bologne 12 morts et 48 blessés par
l'explosion d'une bombe à retardement
alors j'ajoute que le trafic ferroviaire
est considérablement perturbé en italie
puisque bologne est une plaque tournante
d'autre part j'apprends que le pape jean
paul ii informé de cette catastrophe
envoyer un message au cardinal
archevêque de la ville de bologne pour
faire part de son émotion et de sa peine
les jeux de la 22e olympiades sont quasi
finie
cette dernière journée d'épreuves
rapporte encore deux médailles à la
france deux médailles d'argent l'une
pour angelo parisi qui n'a pas réussi en
judo toutes catégories a raflé la
médaille d'or qu'il avait obtenu en
lourd et puis l'autre et c'est une
surprise pour alain lebas en canoë kayak
à l'alba 27 ans qui habite romainville
en seine-saint-denis et qui est
fonctionnaire de police de son métier
alors au total la france rapporte 14
médailles dont 6 en or 5 en argent et 3
en bronze
demain à moscou ce sera la clôture des
jeux comme prévu aucun sportif français
ne participera à la cérémonie
nos athlètes qui donc les uns après les
autres la capitale soviétique
mais auparavant certains comme ville
avait promis ont été reçus par les
autorités soviétiques afin de faire part
de leurs préoccupations face au problème
du droit de l'homme en union soviétique
également et préoccupation de voir la
politique empiéter sur le domaine
sportif
c'est ainsi qu'aujourd'hui josé marajo
véronique gandrille eux et plusieurs de
leurs camarades ont rencontré monsieur
leonid zamiatine le responsable des
questions internationales au kremlin et
vladimir popov du comité d'organisation
des jeux ces athlètes viennent d'arriver
à paris où les attend pierre salviac et
je pense que dans le courant de ce
journal nous pourrons les entendre
monsieur popov en tout cas a qualifié
l'entretien qu'il a eu avec les athlètes
de francs et amicale
je suis d'accord at il dit
avec ce qu'ils m'ont dit mais sauf sur
un point celui demandant la libération
des personnes détenues en union
soviétique pour leurs opinions
car a précisé monsieur popov il n'y a
pas de prisonniers d'opinion dans mon
pays
fin de citation d'autres athlètes
français avait choisi d'autres méthodes
pour participer à la lutte pour les
droits de l'homme ainsi jean michel
bélot perchiste malheureux des jeux nous
expliquait dans sablier ennemis qu'il a
rencontré georges marchais à moscou pour
lui demander d'intervenir afin de faire
libérer la femme du physicien edward
lawrence qui vous avez vu samedi dernier
dans ce journal monsieur l'auzance qui
dialoguait depuis ce studio avec son
épouse retenu à moscou et bien c'est à
partir de là que jean michel bellot a
accompli sa déjà eu l'occasion de le
rencontrer au stade charléty à paris
j'ai repris contact ensuite avec lui
avant de partir aux jeux olympiques
car dans la détresse de sauteurs j'ai
senti comme une responsabilité au fond
d'eux-mêmes pour je me suis juré
d'essayer de faire quelque chose et j'ai
essayé de profiter de l'opportunité de
la présence de georges marchais à moscou
enfin disons lequel je lui eus au
téléphone ces derniers m'a dit que j'ai
raconté mon histoire s'il me dit qu'une
intervention avait déjà été faite à
propos d dans le sang ce qui qui
allaient réitéré sa demande de visa pour
sa femme et que il nous tient au courant
voilà bon ce n'est pas une façon de
mettre hors marché au pied du mur
absolument pas en aucune façon je
mélange marche au pied du mur gg sens et
éventuellement profiter de l'opportunité
se présente c'est tout car je pense que
georges marchais a peut-être plus de
faillites de facilité que quiconque pour
pour arriver à faire sortir cette femme
de l'urss actuellement voilà et tabarly
alors qu'est-il devenu
eh bien vous le voyez les toujours sur
son bateau il y a plus de vent et son
arrivée la trinité sur mer n'est pas
prévu avant demain
tabarly je vous le rappelle a battu le
record de la traversée de l'atlantique à
voile on nous en a longuement parlé hier
et puisque nous en sommes à la voix j'en
profite pour vous dire que dans le tour
de france la sixième étape saint malo
roscoff a été remporté par le bateau le
havre devant menton et la rochelle au
classement général brest consolide sa
première place
les grands départs la situation
s'améliore après les heures difficiles
de ce matin car tout le monde a semblé
vouloir partir en même temps les
vacanciers les amateurs de week-end les
étrangers venus nous rendre visite
total beaucoup de bouchons certains
subsistent encore dans le sud-ouest
entre angoulême et la côte basque via
bordeaux
s'il est trop tôt pour faire le bilan on
dit déjà au centre routier de road ni
même si cela paraît contradictoire que
les automobilistes suivent de mieux en
mieux les consignes de bison futé comme
dans ce matin la situation était très
préoccupante peut-être même par instants
dramatiques alors qu'en est il
aujourd'hui samedi en fin d'après midi
elle est actuellement la situation
d'euros 2e plus clair en quelque sorte
les bouchons se résorbe rica petit
évidemment il en reste encore mais je
pense que d'ici ce soir ils seront
pratiquement disparu malgré l'accès
préférentiel des français qui demeure
toujours sud-ouest et sud-est les
conseils pour ce soir demain dimanche et
lundi
point ils sont très simple il suffit de
partir assez tard dans la nuit
ne pas hésiter à prendre la route de
nuit comme on peut le remarquer
d'ailleurs à l'heure actuelle il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui le font de
plus en plus et les retourne on parle
pas du tout qu'est-ce qui se passerait
en retour c'est assez curieux parce que
justement ils sont très diluée je me
demande ce qui se passe je pense
d'ailleurs et nous le pensons tous ici
que les gens ou étaler leurs vacances et
sans doute rentrons au cours de la
première décade du mois d'août bison
futé a fait du très bon travail et bison
futé dit ceci ne partez pas entre telle
et telle période mais il dit aussi si
vous voulez partir voilà ce à quoi vous
vous exposez durant les heures et les
jours que nous déconseillons alors
partant de là avec le système des radios
périphériques is you avec les coûte que
tout un chacun possède maintenant dans
sa voiture mais bien les gens de plus en
plus écoute les conseils de bison futé
pour notre plus grande satisfaction
d'ailleurs
enfin est-ce que vous pensez tout de
même que ce problème de l'étalement non
pas des vacances parce que là il ne faut
pas rêver mais des départs le pouvoir se
résout un jour ou l'autre
oui c'est certain il faudra un gros
efforts de toutes les parties en
présence
je pense qu'à ce partir de ce moment-là
et fort non seulement des gens des
employeurs et des employés mais aussi
l'effort des gens qui louent alors à
partir ce moment là on pourra arriver à
faire une vaste moment de coordination à
l'échelon national à l'étranger l'egypte
demande le report de la réunion
d'alexandrie sur l'autonomie
palestinienne qui devait commencer
demain report jusqu'à la remise d'un
message du président sadate au premier
ministre israélien begin message qui a
trait au vote par la knesset le
parlement israélien faisant de jérusalem
unifiée est la capitale de l'état
d'israël
l'union soviétique envoient des renforts
militaires importants en europe dans les
pays du pacte de varsovie et
particulièrement en république
démocratique allemande
l'information émane d'un document
confidentiel interallié à bruxelles
malgré le démenti de l' agence tu as
cette nouvelle inquiète les occidentaux
qui ont l'impression d'avoir été floués
lorsque récemment les soviétiques
parlait et prêchait pour la détente et
la réduction des armements en europe
l'analyse des douars lors c'était le 6
octobre dernier il ya moins d'un an en
annonçant un retrait des troupes
soviétiques stationnés en allemagne de
l'est
leonid brejnev avait qualifié son geste
de contributions unilatérale de l'union
soviétique à la détente
en un mot le numéro un soviétique
semblait dire aux occidentaux
vous voyez nous sommes les seuls à faire
quelque chose pour la détente
effectivement moscou a annoncé hier la
fin du retrait des vingt mille hommes et
2000 chars qui viennent donc de quitter
l'allemagne de l'est
mais simultanément on a pu avoir
connaissance de deux rapports l'un des
services secrets américains qui signale
l'arrivée de dix mille hommes et de 200
chars pour renforcer les divisions
soviétiques stationnés en
tchécoslovaquie en pologne
l'autre cette fois un rapport qui arrive
de bruxelles les milieux de l'otan
annonçant l'arrivée en allemagne de
l'est de 990 nouveaux tanks soviétiques
et le renforcement du matériel des 14
divisions qui sont installés tous les
experts ont en fait constaté que les
chars qui ont quitté l'allemagne de
l'est
étaient de vieux t62 remplacés par des
engins beaucoup plus moderne l'été 72
alors sans chercher à juger ce que le
mot détente signifie pour les dirigeants
soviétiques
on peut tout de même constater que
moscou se livre un double jeu on enlève
ici ou là avec un grand renfort de
publicité mais on renforce ailleurs dans
le plus grand secret nous avons nous
même vécu cette tactique il ya moins
d'un mois en afghanistan à kaboul en
voyant arriver sur place du matériel
beaucoup plus adapté à la guérilla alors
que les soviétiques toujours en signe de
détente avait annoncé le départ de dix
mille hommes du territoire afghan que
l'on n'est attribué cet étrange
conception de la détente au fait que
l'union soviétique entendait ne pas voir
complètement s'écrouler leurs jeux
olympiques
c'est une possibilité mais dans quelques
heures ces mêmes jeux olympiques seront
terminés et n'est pas impossible que les
occidentaux demandent alors à moscou
quelques explications sur leur
conception de la détente et pas de
détente non plus en afghanistan où l'on
annonce des bombardements soviétique
dans la province de ghazni dans l'est du
pays ses violentes attaques ont pour but
de réduire une mutinerie qui se
propagent au sein d'unités afghane
et puis on a appris aussi ce matin qu'un
général soviétique avaient été tuées à
kaboul dans un attentat
ce général coordonnait le travail
d'espionnage à la frontière du pakistan
et de l'afghanistan
je vous parlais tout à l'heure du retour
de marajo à orly venant de moscou et
bien le voici nous sommes en direct avec
orly et pierre salviac
oui l'équipe de france qui vient
d'arriver à orly josé marajo et toute
l'équipe de france a commencé par joseph
haram qui est le porte parole d'ailleurs
du groupe josé marajo si vous permettez
de la peur et si joseph à rome qui vient
de lire un communiqué et qui va pouvoir
commenter ce communiqué première
question joseph haram impression de
votre entretien ce matin monsieur papa
lors de l'entretien était très bonne
nous avons pu poser des questions que
nous
on est nous avons obtenu des réponses
alors vous préciser par exemple quel
genre de questions puisqu'il appareils
dans cet entretien est dans le
communiqué que vous venez de lire
il n'a pas été question par exemple de
l'afghanistan pourquoi ça ne vous
intéresse pas ben c'est pas que nous
intéresse pas nous sommes pas venus au
spo jeux olympiques pour parler de
l'afghanistan une somme tout d'abord
venus pour participer à une olympiade
bon il est dommage que certains athlètes
où certains pays ne plus envoyer le plus
tôt sa retraite n'est plus se rendent
aux jeux olympiques mais nous sommes
venus tout d'abord parlé de la défense
des droits de l'homme et de la liberté
d'opinion et de penser simplement il
apparaît que vous n'avez pas cité de nom
particulier vous ne vous êtes pas
attaché à la personnalité d'un dissident
plus qu'un autre
non c'est tout la voir ce sont eux qui
nous ont cité des dissidents et dont
c'était le monde sakharov en nous
proposant simplement de lui envoyer même
des cartes postales et se chargerait
même de les faire parvenir et s'avoue
satisfait ben y'a pas que ça ne sommes
pas venus que pour parler de sakharov où
on à en poser d'autres questions je les
ai vus dans le communiqué tout à l'heure
vous n'aviez qu'à le quel film et
premier set c'était particulièrement
intéressant mais il reste qu'une
déclaration sans suite
c'est pas tout à fait ce qu'ils
attendent peut-être une partie des
français à une partie des français
savaient nous sommes aussi qu'une petite
minorité nous sommes des sportifs ne
sommes peut-être mais dites nous
voyageons ce que nous pouvons nous avons
pensé dans notre conscience que en urss
et se passer quelque chose nous avons
essayé de le dire bon je pense que
certaines personnes l'ont entendu et que
ce sera reportée dans dans ton pays et
que dans d'autres pays c'est tout ce que
nous avons dit en or et c'est valable
aussi pour d'autres pays mais sur votre
déclaration n'a pas été très bien
accueilli évidemment si vous avez eu des
médailles
quelles rues soient pas été très bien
accueilli par les journalistes ce matin
je me suis laissé dire que vous aviez
été insulté c'est vrai on a été insultée
parce que
on ne pensions pas faire une conférence
de presse dès le matin parce qu'on était
pressé par le temps pour rentrer à paris
simplement mais a autrement dit vous
êtes bien mal à joseph haram donc de
retour de moscou
interrogé par pierre salviac en direct
d'orly un signal d'alarmé déclenché la
semaine dernière par deux événements un
signal d'alarmé
pas très agréable à entendre parce
qu'ils se nomment racisme
le premier événement c'était il ya une
semaine à anvers en belgique
un attentat contre des enfants juifs a
coûté la vie à un jeune parisien
on vous l'a dit l'autre a pour cadre la
rue des rosiers hier matin à paris un
jeune infirme juif a été gravement
matraqué et blessé par sept hommes armés
parce qu'il avait pris la défense d'un
vieil homme musulman
et comme ce n'est pas le premier
incident de ce genre dans ce quartier où
vit une communauté israélite importante
on s'inquiète beaucoup c'est vraiment
très très grande parce que je me sens
moi-même concernés ma famille a quand
même assez souffert d'antisémitisme de
racisme et
et je me sens vraiment profondément
concernés si vous êtes né pourtant
française où je suis né en france mais
de parents polonais rescapés de lost de
l'holocause c'est
non
la mission vous êtes nés en france c'est
ce que vous pouviez pensé il ya quelques
années que cet antisémitisme pouvait un
jour vos ned pour les raisons tout à
fait obscures à j'ai toujours pensé
enfin aussi loin que mes souvenirs
m'habite oui j'ai toujours pensé
est ce que vous sentez qu'à une
recrudescence ou non parce que vous avez
vécu également à ce que j'ai vécu il ya
quelques années j'ai impression
coupablement probablement parce que je
suis plus consciente des problèmes en
vieillissant on est toujours plus
conscients des problèmes vous vivez dans
ce quartier comment réagissent les
jeunes juifs autour de vous aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ajoute défense qu'à moi
com
vous ne pensez pas que c'est les besoins
son sens parce que
parce qu'on était entre guillemets
toléré alors qu'aujourd'hui bon
c'est dans la partie intégrante de ses
dépens vous êtes inquiète
il y a des ça dépend cse il ya des jours
où on aimerait se dire que ce genre
d'acte est vraiment isolé qui ne
signifie pas grand chose mais il ya des
moments où on s'inquiète un peu parce
qu'on se demande
ça va pas aller en s'amplifiant jean
françois kahn pour reprendre
l'expression de cette femme acte isolé
ou au contraire c'est beaucoup plus
grave selon vous mais il faut il faut
dans ce genre d'affaires se garder je
crois de deux tendances également
dangereuse la tendance à exagérer à
dramatiser mais aussi la tendance à
minimiser
car nous trouvons actuellement en france
devant un certain nombre de phénomènes
nouveaux et qui sont les faits assez
inquiétant les quêtes
d'abord je dirais une globalisation du
racisme jusqu'à présent en france le
racisme était spécifiquement anti arabes
et anti noir il n'en était pas moins
condamnable mais disons qu'on n'osait
pas être antisémite parce que les
souvenirs des horreurs de la guerre
était encore très proche
or il semble que maintenant on ose on
n'ose plus les souvenirs des horreurs du
nazisme s'éloigne plus on ose à être
anti noir anti algérienne anti arabe et
aussi antisémite et anti n'importe quoi
d'autre pourquoi pas la voilà premier
phénomène
le deuxième phénomène c'est que sont
apparus ces derniers temps des commandos
qui attaquent des gens au faciès est à
dire qu'ils se sont mis à attaquer des
gens simplement parce qu'ils sont noirs
parce qu'ils sont arabes ou parce qu'ils
sont juifs et qui les ont attaqués avec
sauvagerie avec sadisme au point de les
laisser presque comores dans la rue ça
c'est le deuxième phénomène
le troisième phénomène c'est
l'apparition de groupuscules il ne faut
pas dire d'extrême droite car l'extrême
droite en démocratie on a tout à fait le
droit d d'extrême droite quand on a le
droit d d'extrême gauche n'est pas
condamnable deux groupes ouvertement néo
nazis c'est à dire deux groupes qui se
disent franchement fasciste de groupes
qui exhibent des croix gammées deux
groupes qui se réclament mais
franchement de la morale des waffen ss
et ça c'est tout à fait nouveau en
france
alors ces trois phénomènes si vous
voulez je crois qu'il faut et je le
répète parce qu'il me ça me semble
important il faut ni en exagérer
l'ampleur comme le font parfois
certaines organisations juives mais on
les comprend ni en minimiser le danger
l'importance comme a tendance parfois à
le faire la police car vous savez on a
déjà vu dans l'histoire des drames
terribles commencé simplement par
l'action
de quelques groupuscules j'apprends à
l'instant le nouveau bilan de
l'explosion de bologne dont nous vous
parlions en tête de ce journal
l'explosion de bologne a fait 76 morts
selon un nouveau bilan officiel selon le
commandant de la police municipale de
bologne
ce bilan provisoire devrait encore
s'aggraver dans les heures prochaines
plusieurs blessés se trouvant toujours
dans un état désespéré
et j'ajoute que l'on sait toujours rien
de précis quant à l'origine de cette
explosion mais qui n'est pas un attentat
visiblement tout à fait autre chose la
carte d'identité informatisées c'est
maintenant certain fera son apparition à
partir du mois de novembre vous pourrez
obtenir si vous faites renouveler votre
carte actuelle ou si vous faites une
première demande de carte d'identité
comment serez vous habiller cet automne
mesdames
la question est posée chaque année à
cette saison les collections battent
leurs plans collection de leur plein
plutôt collection de haute couture celle
qu'on exporte aussi à l'étranger
c'est pourquoi de nombreux confrères
étrangers sont venus voir ce qui se fait
à park
martine laroche-joubert donc suivi les
collections en compagnie de libido re
c'est du eyrolles triviaux et b dorcé
collectionneuse de collection par ce
matin à faire l'ouverture
accompagné de charlie 100 photographes à
l'affût un défilé chez balmain première
embuscade pour la plume et le regard
acéré db prennent de ce monde de
chiffons pour à la meilleure chaises
pour aller révérence des couturiers même
celle de balma qui murmure-t-on ici nabi
pas moins d'une demi-douzaine de têtes
couronnées
non ça peu près égale ça c'est du retard
en chine
dans une une dalle en verre où les
célébrités et les stars se kento par
terre et baie rempli sa gibecière des
poupées et d'information placé à côté de
pacquiao fort de la star 2010 elle
recueille une information de première
main
oui edward maintiendra sa candidature à
la présidence des états unis
la longueur des ourlets l'intéressent
moi finalement qu'une certaine
atmosphère
la priorité va pas du tout
parce que qu'est ce que vous ressentez
quand vous écrivez un article sur la
mode ça parce qu'après tout d'amour vous
pouvez à s'estimer aventuriers personnes
sans problème
d'un côté c'est pas c'est pas important
parce que il n'ya que 1500 femmes homos
qui passait bien en clôture et là me
plaisait c'est très important parce qu'à
travers dans l'essence il avait démis
encore des millions de gens envoyés au
casse qui avaient pratiqué une
collection quand même là ça peut avoir
des conséquences justement sur ce
problème des listes on peut évidemment
mais ça c'est pas mon problème c'est
leur problème n'est pas que la presse
puisse y ait quoi que ce soit si les
gens ont du talent et les annonces à
tous c'est le problème des couturiers
car ces défilés de mode sont entre
autres une vaste opération publicitaire
pour maintenir l'éclat de leurs noms
qu'il menait affichées sur des foulards
des bagages du prêt-à-porter et toutes
sortes de produits
et l'on comprend mieux les attentions
dont est entouré et b d'orsay dont les
chroniques sont lus dans le monde entier
elle s'en défend mais elle a la dent
dure et cette année elle a intitulé son
article sur dior un bâillement
on devine aussi l' angoisse de pierre
cardin qui lui a vendu 550 et une fois
sans nom
tél
déjà polar à rien
pas la peine
et
des visages
on passe à l'avenir
attendez vite par toi vite
et puis un pèlerinage nous plaçons
l'endroit exact où mademoiselle chanel
surveiller sans être vu le défilé les
spectateurs coco chanel qui elle n'avait
pas peur de voir ses idées descendre
dans la rue
c'est au fur et à mesure que les femmes
dont mabille a présenté sa vie dans le
monde on disparaît bon alors il n'y aura
plus besoin de faire des essayages et
tout ça donc ce côté qui avait encore
une toute petite badré elle va partir et
à son bras évidemment on pourra plus à
dire que ce sera la culture ce sera
plutôt les idées communes et cardin à la
banderole idée qui s'appliqueront après
diffusé pendant les collections un rite
le rite aussi classique que la robe de
mariée
merci
l'enfant chéri des chroniqueuses yves
saint laurent
à
oh
collection oui très et même après g si
on n'est pas encourager autant
abandonner parce que c'est beaucoup trop
difficile et beaucoup de trous war 2
des portes alors c'est un espèce demi
finales dont il la haute couture et
qui aux collections être évité par
exemple si j'en avais deux ou trois sur
tous les abonnements mauvais papier
contre bauchi font un match qui durera
même si personne n'a plus les moyens de
s'offrir ces robes laboratoire car la
roue volera toujours leur esprit
deauville capitale des amoureux du
cheval en ce mois d'août non seulement à
cause des tiercés qui se dérouleront
dans la ville normande
chaque dimanche mais aussi parce que
deauville verra bien d'autres événements
où le cheval sera roi pierrette brès les
chevaux de course sont eux aussi besoin
de changement d'ère et de vacances
meeting de deauville qui vient de
commencer leur donnera l'occasion de
profiter des bannières bénéfique à leurs
jambes si fragile deauville en août
c'est le mois capitale des courses lance
hâtivement salle des ventes qui attire
chaque année les acheteurs du monde
entier des véritables fortunes change de
mains pour l'acquisition de yearlings au
pedigree prestigieux les propriétaires
japonais saoudiens ou américains
n'hésitent pas à offrir des centaines de
millions pour des produits mâle ou
femelle née du célèbre lifar par exemple
l'un de nos meilleurs étalons tous les
jours des courses plates ou à obstacles
se déroule sur l'hippodrome de la
touques ou de clairefontaine qui sert
aussi le matin deux pistes
d'entraînement dimanche 1er tiercé de la
côte normande dans le puits des
chaînettes une course à handicap pour
chevaux âgés de 3 ans et qui se courra
sur 2000 m les entraîneurs réservé
prépare tout spécialement certains
poulains et pouliches pur deauville à
nous de découvrir ceux qui ont
particulièrement visé cette course all
of power sera la base de mon tiercé
il vient de participer à l'arrivée de
deux récentes courses et malgré son
poids élevé 56 kg il pourrait bien
gagner ce tiercé dont menotti ne devrait
pas vous décevoir la piste de deauville
lui convient tout à fait
sa rade et un poulain très nerveux si
son jockey arrive à le calmer avant le
sprint final il a toutes ses chances
pour l'interdît lord les commence
seulement à montrer ce dont il est
capable il est conseillé de suivre chez
qui ça n a fait de gros progrès
de plus son poids est avantageux 48 kg
l'indésirable est acquis noah sort mais
outsider mais je terminerais ma
sélection avec beau château et ses
chevaux porteront les numéros 2 6 11 8
19 17 3 16
voilà c'est noté je crois que je ne me
tromperai pas en vous précisant que vous
avez été plusieurs millions à dire en
même temps et à longueur de journée
qu'est-ce qui fait chaud 36° à clermont
ferrand 33 à marseille 32 à strasbourg
dijon et lyon 31 par inanciers tour 28
seulement à cannes et nice et 22h rbds
et pour demain et bien pour demain ce
sera à peu près la même chose sauf dans
l'ouest où il fera un peu moins chaud
pour le reste une zone nuageuse avec
parfois des ondées orageuses se rassit
que le matin de la normandie hollande
elle gagna en soirée les régions qui
vont des ardennes et des vosges au
massif central et aux pyrénées à l'avant
de cette zone
le temps sera donc lourd et chaud comme
aujourd'hui
ce journal est terminée je vous souhaite
de passer une très bonne soirée à
l'ecoute d'antenne 2 dans une pièce
climatisée de préférence en attendant le
dernier journal qui aura lieu à 0,25 et
qui vous sera présenté par pierre alain
je vous retrouve demain à 12h45
bonsoir